on va travailler pour l'équipe nationale
des déficients mentaux
ça pose aucun problème toi on va pas
faire jouer aux handicapés tu veux pas
les aider c'est un gamin je lève les
yeux au ciel et après tu parles on
s'appelle stanislas a été un rendez vous
chez l'ophtalmo qui a été prévu on va
quand même faire un petit examen sûr je
fais choper on va être les maîtres les
plus détestés la planète c'est pas grave
les gars font la fête ensemble c'est
parce qu'on vous chacun de notre côté
mais ensemble on forme une [ __ ] de
l'équipe
[Musique]
elle joue quoi je suis l'entraîneur de
l'équipe nationale de basket pour les
déficients mentaux et cherche des
joueurs comme toi ah mais je suis pas
handicapé je fais nouvel éducateur avons
regardé quoi les gars y'a un mec qui
recrutent des joueurs pros faire une
équipe de quartier on va pas car je
voudrais aux handicapés et l'esprit
olympique où tu fais ce que tu veux
manger mais qui patine
on va travailler pour l'essence pour
l'équipe nationale les déficients
mentaux
je vous en ai connu des premières dès
lors à une prime pour chaque victoire
si on veut sauver une fédération des
handicapés
bah ouais 75 sagittaire mon nom c'est
freddy depuis tout petit je m'appelle
comme ça ça pose aucun problème toi tu
veux pas les aider c'est pour garder
c'est vraiment des nids sont vraiment
cool paraît effectivement ils sont cools
falloir être crédible dans le village
olympique qui lève les yeux au ciel et
après tu parles oui parfait on dit ah
ben stanislas a essayé un rendez vous
chez l'ophtalmo qui était prévu aux
messieurs si vous perdiez autour de moi
je travaille avec la fédération dont je
vais vous accompagner pendant la
compétition tu joues à quel poste à nice
la bonne heure on va quand même faire un
petit examen juste pour se rassurer
franck nra tu respectes haut ce que je
dis que je suis capitaine ouais c'est le
capitaine
si on se fait choper on va être là me
fait plus détesté de la planète
vas-y tu voulais expliquer par exemple
n'en parle
freddy personne alors à te dire comment
tu as ta bille et personne à droite
interdire de rouler une pelle et 9
on va faire tout ce qu'on peut pour toi
la ramener je te promets c'est pour
yoann offredo je veux la gagner cette
finale
donc on a vraiment fait une connerie
c'est pas grave les gars font la fête
ensemble
[Musique]
[ __ ] j'ai créé un monstre